let's do it
ladies and gentlemen welcome to
a very special edition of your favorite
podcast
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome terrific
crossover episode with my other podcast
Jen to Shen I talk about it but I want
to show The Ripping with Griffin
audience what that podcast is all about
so I'm gonna play an episode of that one
today
um but you know thanks for being here
so we gonna do it it's me my buddy
Matthew Espinosa and the Great Dane Cook
so welcome to
gym
yes welcome to Griffin with Griffin
special edition Gen 2 gen uh it's a
podcast with me my buddy Matthew
Espinosa I'm 50 he's 25 and we talk
about different things and we had some
guests so we have about 30 something
episodes we're trying to get some
traction so I've decided I'm gonna do
this I'm going to play one of our one of
our
um
it was a fun episode with the Great Dane
Cook and I just had Dane on recently and
I thought you know what he's got his
special out above it all and so uh let's
uh do a replay of the Janda Jan episode
and as usual thanks for being here guys
uh
you know hit the Subscribe uh you know
what I mean hit the Subscribe
um what else I'm on Twitch most days hit
me up on Twitch and if you want to help
support the podcast you can you can help
support on patreon
and you can do it
you're gonna do that so nothing really
else to report
uh next week I'll be back talking about
a bunch of stuff that's going on in the
world you know like this Kyrie Irving
thing uh you know follow up with um
some more uh reviews and previews
watching this great new show some of
this I think it's the bastard son of the
devil new show on Netflix it's out of
Europe I think it's like a British show
but it's really good so I'll talk to
about that talk to you about that next
week and uh look out for also the new
version of King and the thing make sure
you guys check that podcast out too
because that got a big surprise coming
big changes to that one coming so
anyways right now let's just get to it
so this is an episode of gen to gen uh
with me Matthew Espinosa and we had a
guest on the Great Dane Cook thanks for
watching
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
episode of
Jen to Jen episode five yes uh Matthew
Espinosa and I'm Eric Griffin Griffin
and my longtime friend can I not talk
I'm being introduced can we introduce
you
can we man I was like do I just sit here
in the middle and just like what if what
if what if we never talk to you how long
would I wait now
I jump in pretty quick eventually just
gets out just leaves all right Dane Cook
everybody Dane Cook hello yes we you
know uh you know so you know it's Jen to
Jen uh you know as his generation versus
Our Generation because we're the same
age first yeah yeah
every episode starts off with a good old
good old arm wrestle uh we know we just
uh we decided to do this thing uh
because you know it's we learn from each
other which is something that people
don't normally do right you know so
we've had a bunch of young people on and
we've I've learned from them and and I
thought you know let's get some other
people on and I actually you guys are
actually pretty similar in my eyes in
terms of like you really have a great
work ethic in terms of like just a great
work ethic uh he knew how to once he got
into the social media
boom it took off and you're you were the
same way and what do you think was the
very first I'm not gonna ask you a
question yet no no I feel like I'm still
are we still in intro mode no no no no
we're in it now we're in all right five
seconds I feel like it's pretty quick uh
people who are early adopters of
understanding like oh this is how I want
to connect with people but not just in a
Superfluous way like I'm selling you on
something but like let me let me go on
this journey of my artistic growth with
an audience of people who will hopefully
bring more people into The Fray was that
what you were discovering right away
that you had that like that uh quick
route you know relationship with people
for sure because you know growing up I
always looked at actors and and writers
and all that stuff and it's there's has
this mysterious tone to them you know
before the internet it had like unless
you're seeing them on the screen you're
not seeing them out you know so it
started becoming this oh the more we
know about you the more we like you type
thing and then you also have to to
balance this accessibility that you're
giving them so you could still have your
own private life so yeah I noticed that
at a pretty early age that people
enjoyed that personality that I was
giving them so I kind of really dove
into that but it started getting a
little messy when I didn't know how much
access like I you know mentioned right
how much till the magic of who you've
become on the screen is diluted because
they know what you use to brush your
teeth and like and what pillow you sleep
on and and this right all that so what
is so yeah let's that's kind of
interesting jumping off point because I
think as a person who also like yourself
was like oh this is uh this is a portal
yeah right to finding audience to
building that fan base but how do I keep
the magic of uh you know TMI so that
when they they want to come see my show
or they want to see me in a in a film
role or take on something different like
what is too much social media I I just
think right now we're we're a state
where we're we're changing the rules as
we go and I think that there that there
is such a thing as there is too much or
maybe that's now just enough maybe
that's the normal you know because you
know the mysterious of like I don't know
if some of the stars from our childhood
that were super mega Stars could have
been super mega stars with social media
right they did it differently I don't
know if Michael Jackson would have been
as big I don't know if OJ would have
been as big I don't know if like you
know what I mean like it it's there's
Michael Jordan even I could have Michael
Jordan have dealt with social media the
way say LeBron James is dealing with
social media they have a different path
of super stardom there's also that like
who would have had foot and mouth
disease to where they said too much or
put a bad onus on their brand or
whatever because maybe not everybody
knows how to have that conversation man
not everybody's good at editing on the
fly like that now that's the interesting
word you said brand so were you always
aware of your brand like when it when it
first card because like you want to talk
about ground floor okay yeah this guy's
ground floor all right yeah I'm talking
about you saw Myspace as a way of being
like oh you know what I can get butts in
the seats with this I can engage with my
fans like whatever the thought process
was it was a lot of things yes that now
people just take for granted you know
yeah so were you were you brand building
at that point did you you know I was but
it's it's tying into what what you're
also putting up which was I had 10 years
on the road before the internet really
you know kind of caught on and so I had
all these college age kids that were
coming up or people that see me in clubs
and now I finally had this portal where
we could a hub right everybody can come
onto this Myspace page yeah and so right
off the bat I found that I had like
several thousand people that were
finding me right away
as soon as the interaction started
within a week I was like this is it one
week and I went this is going to
continue to grow I know that my Hub is
gonna just you know if I put out good
content so immediately I was thinking
branding because I put on my very first
mission statement if you're going to be
a fan of mine if you're going to follow
me here don't follow me unless you're a
fan of risks because I'm going to take a
lot of them it was it was a excuse for
me to kind of up a little bit and say
I'm going to do some stuff that's not
like the same you know pattern yeah from
other comics for sure that that gave me
a bit of a like okay that's all right if
somebody Taps out and yet I felt it also
allowed people to go oh what is what is
this journey going to be and that that
wasn't a one-trick pony start it was
that that the ability to go I'm gonna
grow and change as a person because I'm
going to evolve I'm gonna be ignorant
sometimes I'm Gonna Learn I'm gonna [__]
up hopefully they'll let me grow Express
regret rat uh talk about you know
highlight real moments if I wanna in in
a way that's not like I'm not boasting
but I am in terms of branding I always
thought of it like we
we are on this journey I don't think I
ever used it I didn't go I got this
thing I booked guys look what we did
yeah we did this and I made them a part
of that kind of production team now when
you say so I didn't call it branding but
I definitely was understanding I was
heading up with a generation that's
start this is their golden age of
Television is now that's what they used
to call by the way the gold nature
television way back because there was
nothing else but this was the Golden Age
of the next thing and I knew I was a
part of it so you know do you feel
though that there was like a little bit
of a little bit of like a leeway a
little bit of rope being a comic you
know like when you say hey why make some
mistakes also the times right because if
you think now right because I would say
that Matt is very aware of the things
that he says like he's not you're not
gonna catch him on the internet doing
some willy willy willy-nilly stuff right
and somebody being like I can't believe
it what's willy-willy
there's willy nilly
you know so I I feel like you know uh
and him just being aware of that he's
very uh you know he's very he this is
he's like hey this kind of person
because I'm a good family but are you
different but are you then doing that to
a point where this is going to be a
tough thing to answer like everything's
shut off and you're looking in the
mirror is your integrity intact where
you're like I'm really living as honest
as I possibly can while things are
rolling or are you going I'm a little
aware of things that I'm saying and
doing and does it make you feel like
when everything goes off do you go do
you go and breathe in a sigh of like oh
I feel great or do you go
well I think at the end of the day I
just I really do understand the
responsibility I have with the audience
I have and and also understanding the
age of the audience I have you know at
the end of the day yeah I'm not perfect
and I'm not always making the right
decisions but at the end of the day I
know what I can put on the internet and
what I shouldn't put on the internet for
the most part and I know that if I can
make a video and make someone laugh
without cursing for instance or making a
crude joke then I'll go for that because
I know I have a long career and I can do
that at a certain point eventually but
right now I know that there's younger
kids watching me and I just know that's
my responsibility and that's just cool
that's just who I am personally not
everyone wants to take down and that's
fine that's but that's just who I am
that's my parents have been like dude
I've just raised me that way so you
could probably even look at
um you know kind of unfortunately it's
like some of the we grew up with like
the Disney kid generation and some of
them didn't make it out alive because
they were so homogenized and so one
branding yeah one brand they were afraid
to grow up or maybe the people around
them didn't want to see them change
there's also a money thing too man it's
like this is your brand like look at
Hannah Montana look at my I was gonna
say Miley Cyrus you know you're like if
you're making millions of dollars being
this thing right and then and then you
go and you're a kid and then like you're
going through puberty and you're going
through like hey can I can I not
experimental yeah can I not be a kid
anymore can I like boys can I like this
can I go out on and then she just went
of course we just witnessed her whole
rebellious yeah but unfortunately she
was so famous we we got to witness it to
the point where she's at this place now
where she's just got a totally different
place I've seen her on podcasts and
stuff and I go oh man you've grown from
all of them yeah it seemed to inform her
right and some people it
um
I don't know maybe not everybody's ready
to grow the way she did at those moments
but we've seen it's a detriment to some
people that too much of that I watched
the um so uh Charlie and uh the demili
demilio oh yeah the demilio I watched
that documentary I said the demilio
twins they're not twins right sisters so
I watched the uh I happen to see like
three or four episodes were on Hulu and
I had it on in my office and next thing
you know I'm watching it and I found
them to be very uh like they were almost
over sharing but in a way that I was
like wow this is probably very healthy
because they're they're letting it all
out in that kind of moment and I felt
like uh respect I respected that it was
like okay there some people might tap
out and be like this is not I just
wanted the tick tock dancing and I just
wanted to do the service level aspect of
the social media things I don't want to
dive this deep I don't want this many
layers to on a public hit Level I'll
tell you I'll tell you one little thing
I've learned in my I'm 49 and I've been
in the business for 30 years and the one
thing I've seen whether somebody falls
off or they're you know canceled and
they're coming back or many many years
ago they had box office bombs and they
were to blame whatever kind of took
somebody off their route
truth is alluring
when you try to shroud yourself in what
you once were again and say no that's
still me
it's done yeah but truth in being very
transparent
people will come around again I mean
especially nowadays you know like people
can like I was saying back then there
was this mysterious factor to a lot of
people in the entertainment industry
where you don't know a lot about them
but nowadays even if you want to be
someone you're not someone might call
you out for because everyone's got a
camera nowadays everyone's got a phone
so you could act like this person all
day long but
you could easily get called out for it
you know and like transparency is such
the foundation of a lot of the social
media you know influencers nowadays they
want to tell everybody everything but
that's also comes down to because that's
just their goal and we've talked about
this in other episodes where like it all
comes down to what your goal is you know
and if your goal is to be on the
internet if your goal is to gain
followers then yeah give everything do
vlogs every day do you know tell
everyone tell everyone what toothpaste
you use tell everyone what your favorite
brand of deodorant is like people want
that information because then they'll
feel like they know you right but then
there's a slippery slope where they feel
like they know you you know and that's
like double-edged sword right there but
I think also sometimes um
you know uh the truth people want as uh
sometimes negative like the truth they
want is the worst version of ourselves
so they can somehow feel connected in
that way like oh well you're not perfect
so now I feel connected to you you know
it's like it's amazing that so many bad
things happen to people then it get it's
on the internet and then they want to
see like let me hear what happened how
did that happen and then they want to
see how did you recover from that right
right because you get that all the time
and we're not going to talk about this
but you know it's like Dane's brother
did he stole money and you had to deal
with that and everybody was there yeah
you know in public eye yeah humiliation
moments as well as public eye upper
echelon moments having it all out there
and everybody's suddenly uh an opinion
yeah you know somebody they talk to you
like your family and that's not always a
good thing that's a weird thing but you
know another thing she was like what
Matt was saying is like you know again
the thing about everybody having a phone
and in these kind of moments is they
forget that you're a human being so you
might be at Starbucks where the guy just
elbowed You by you know but even if it
wasn't by accident you're having a thing
somebody picks their phone up right at
the moment when you're going hey Jerk
boom boom and then it's like next thing
you know it's like do you cook it's in
the Starbucks coffee but you know what I
mean then you're just like hey and then
you know you don't necessarily get a
moment to be like no no no you don't
know what happened see this has happened
before that so then you find yourself
being like do I have to act a certain
way all the time and then it goes back
to what you said you just go you know
what I'm just gonna live in this truth
right I just had a moment if you don't
like it sorry yeah I learned that from
Patrice O'Neill who's a comedian I came
up with who had passed away and he was
one of the first peace people to tell me
like as a performer if you if you come
from your truth even if it's absurd it
could be some Twisted story that's like
Fantastical if if it means something to
you and you're not bullshitting people
that this that I'm I'm being
introspective because I'm really
fascinated by what I don't even know he
was willing to sit in those moments and
I learned a lot about like okay as long
as I'm
um uh aware in in the narrative is from
me yeah then I could take those hits and
trust me I had to take hits that I was
not yeah yeah that I was certainly not
wanting or expecting but at least at my
lowest moments I was always like
but I know I I'm not having to collect
myself the fragments or the pieces of me
that were false and put together a false
yeah I can put myself together again for
sure and then hopefully from it and
actually hopefully at the time but now
looking back at some of those things I
wouldn't change it those were the things
that actually made me ingratiate myself
with butterfly effect yeah you know a
group of fans that were even more like
dude now we're really on the journey and
rooting for you and then new people that
checked in like didn't know much about
you before but now I'm now I'm
interested you know what I like uh I did
some shows with Dan before the World
Went Crazy
and it was interesting to me he does a
meet and greet before the show and it's
interesting to me to see like new fans
and old fans you know and it's like
people that have been on that Journey
with you right I like that's what I like
yeah you know now they're like here
comes a dude he's like 48. you know what
I mean his wife and they're just like
you can tell he's like saw you in 90
right I'm gonna be at College where's my
daughter they got an old they got an old
dang t-shirt on and they're just like oh
man we still love you and it's just like
Ah that's the thing right there that's
right you know it's like and you seemed
you you like oh this is great you're
like you're like hey thanks for still
being a fan that's right you know what I
mean yeah and you also kind of know that
from where you're coming from people
you you you're probably a fan of things
that you tap out of once in a while ago
ah that that album not my favorite that
version of them and you just do your own
thing yeah but then you swing back
around and go what are they doing now
and and if you don't try to hold on to
everything and everybody all the time
that Turn Style career of people people
come and go yeah you know you'll have
high water marks and you'll have things
that are people like I thought that was
Kaka and it's like oh wow but you know
you might look at something and say I
didn't like that choice you made I go
well that's why I fell in love for the
first time so I don't even care that you
did or didn't like it I know yeah yeah I
had a moment out of that experience you
know what I mean so it's you know what
we're gonna do now is like I was just
about to say we got to go to Matt's
notebook yeah I got some I got some
questions yeah I knew I knew he would
all right
that and this as well yeah you're just
bringing that music everywhere but uh no
the thing was is like what I was going
to ask is based off what you were saying
do you think that and this also goes for
you too do you think you would have done
anything differently if the internet was
there from the gate at the way it is now
do you think you would have
um just anything differently do you
think you would have I don't even know
from the beginning yeah the first 10
years yeah yeah but how different you
think it would have been you know you
know because it comes down to the
transparency thing how we were talking
about you know I often think about some
of the comics that I admire you know and
I and I and I look back at what I've
been watching them in the clubs do for
the past 10 years
and I think to myself they they already
are famous
okay I don't know sometimes if it would
have been the same with the way things
are right now right you know yeah I just
I just don't know like what your sets
have been different what what do you
probably I think you know what I think
it would have helped comedy more I think
being because I find that like uh with
all this transparency we have to try we
have to be more thoughtful you know like
I've done some sets where I've been like
and somebody will be like I didn't like
what you said right and then so
initially I'm like you don't tell me
what I then but I do think about it I go
like okay why did they have that
perspective and it makes me go well
could I is that something that I want to
say do I want to make sure I'm being I'm
saying what I want to say and so so
that's that you know it just it just
goes with the territory so now I don't
know if I would I think it would have
been different there's two things that I
I know when I look back on my early
stand up things that I thought I was not
being ignorant about that I was doing
the smart version of now I look back and
understand oh wow that was the ignorance
I actually thought there was a way to do
an Indian voice in a routine that was
like oh no no I'm propping this person
up I'm not doing what other Comics do
which is making this person look the
fool now I can look back and go that's
that's not my truth that's not I there's
no need to do that voice I can still
tell a story well that was that joke I'm
doing with it
so on one hand there's always going to
be things that you look back on there's
no there's no level of policing that
yeah that is going to keep you from
having to learn about the another
person's experience from from where they
are so keeping an open mind and and
realizing I could not have protected
myself from saying you know ridiculous
for a lot of years and also I didn't
have the spine early in my stand up to
probably
stand by my personal Constitution it
took me a long time and probably getting
battering rammed around the industry a
little bit to finally go oh I know where
I know how to weather storms I know how
to get my you know thick skin and now
I'm ready for sure definitely would not
have wanted uh the internet as the early
part because I would have been false I
would have been trying to
you know people tell you who they are
and then they show you who they are I
would have been telling you a lot
probably not having as much substance
and the thing is with that is you know
how you were talking about where
you know uh people are watching you and
they might come and go and there's fans
who who randomly show up like dude you
know I didn't like that one thing but I
like this other thing of you the the
thing with social media is that you're
seeing these numbers go so you could see
oh this video did well I got a million
views on this one I like this one but
this other one I'm about to put tomorrow
is going to be great I will put this one
out and then that one doesn't do as well
and you're like wait what and then you
start doing all this judging because
you're seeing these numbers right then
and there a lot of the times I feel like
back then you're not seeing these
numbers consistently of like what my fan
base is looking like right now and that
can mess with people's self-esteem and
their confidence you know I think I
think the numbers of it all is uh is uh
probably the worst element of anything
social media I feel bad for so many kids
in school right now because I'm so lucky
I didn't have to deal with that growing
up of like looking like a life you're
sitting in class right now like he has
500 followers I only have 200 followers
right when they're there's just a test
right there there's a science test going
on and this kid's thinking about 500
followers man how am I going to get my
followers up and that that self-esteem
as a sixth grader to mess with oh man I
couldn't even imagine and imagine like
when technology gets even better where
it's like gonna really be like you know
we'll have like Black Mirror yeah we'll
have contact lens
well there was an episode of that yeah I
know remember it was like I'm gonna give
you some lights right now you could hear
chimes in your in the in the cognitive
reality whatever you know the thing that
the thing about your point too is that
you put so you put the video up uh this
is what I think happens a lot right now
too you put this video up it gets a
million views the other one doesn't and
then you put another video up it gets a
million views and you were doing
something wacky in it and now you think
well now I got to be this wacky guy yeah
that's what happens right that's how so
many social media people like they start
with like I'm the guy that does this and
then all of a sudden who like oh we love
that he's like well I gotta keep doing
that
but this is where this is where I'll
chime in and say it goes back then to
goals because if that guy or that girl's
goal is to gain followers then he's
doing or she's doing it exactly what
they need to do if they want to actually
stay consistent on a personal level and
and say no this is my Foundation of who
I am and that's not going to change
regardless of the views and engagement
then their goal is to be or do something
else you know so but if their goal is to
gain that followers would be the biggest
Entertainer because I've heard people on
social media say that I'm going to be
the biggest Entertainer in the world so
they're not going to stop at anything to
get to that point if this means cookies
videos now though thank you what is
being the biggest Entertainer in the
world even means is this based on
followers like yeah you're the biggest
entertainment only a number then you're
in trouble because I don't know if this
is even like it's side item but there's
a lot of bamboozling going on even with
those algorithms and who gets seen what
where and why maybe a story for part two
if you'll have me back of course um of
course but but let me tell you something
we're going to play it by ear let's see
how this one goes yeah
I'll tell you what I I saw growing up
which I've always been a kind of an
analytics in in data in numbers person
it was there my whole life even though
oddly I have discount ocula which
physical like seeing numbers it's like
dyslexia where I get numbers mixed up if
I'm looking at numbers or if I'm trying
to like if you told me your phone number
by the time you get to the last digit I
I can't remember the first couple or I
switched them yeah your brother stole
the money all right well again part two
before three all right maybe part three
yeah okay uh there's people hearing this
for the first time right now like what
I've gone back to concerts
but okay no no but let me let me uh
LeapFrog uh Through Time back which is
so I grew up seeing movies and TV shows
that were considered Duds or failures
and then suddenly you'd call them at the
time like cult classics that meant like
they hung around and then later they
became some of the most successful
movies that that to this day you go like
first Mueller's day off is a classic
comedy now if you watch it today it's
just as funny it was a bomb that's what
empowers was a bomb Austin Powers so I
actually have heard that before but a
lot of movies have been bombs in the
beginning but then when the DV comes out
or something like that or later on but
to anybody listening who's worried about
your numbers I want you to think of this
and I I I'll tell you because I lived
through this when my first album came
out my first comedy album they told me
the uh record company you're only going
to sell 6 000 copies of this maybe now I
sold 20 000 out of my trunk over two
years I said guys no I I guarantee they
fought me on it and when it finally came
out my first album sold 90 000 copies in
the first week now dang they were
excited wow I was excited but I was like
I know this could have done even better
just kind of given my social media
presence think about this for the person
with 200 followers and going like oh but
how can I build my brand up so I when my
next album came out and I was better and
I prepped better and I knew the the the
world better and I knew the world I knew
the behind the scenes I knew how to edit
better I knew the sound things I'd
learned when that album came out and was
successful the first one
the numbers went up so don't think so
create something authentic and let your
full Legacy bolster the catalog later
don't worry about one thing being the
perfect thing yeah and that's what it
comes down to like you said don't
letting one thing be the perfect thing
it comes down to expectations you know
just doing what you do because you love
it you know and and that's why when you
want to upload a video or you want to do
this just do it because you genuinely
enjoy it and that's some so many of the
times that's what happened it'll be like
4am or something like that and I'll
randomly think of an idea 3am that's
like what I'm most creative and then
I'll randomly just make it upload it at
that time and then go to bed and I'll
wake up and like that'll be the video
that has like 10 million views I'm like
what I just what you know what I'm
saying it's like that's because I didn't
put so much thought into it like yes I
know the world on stuff but I just did
it because I love it and that's that you
know and then you know all the other
videos it'll trickle down into all those
and and that's how podcasting works too
man yeah people want to wait until
they're like let me see this I like this
let me go check episode one blah blah
blah you know oh totally I'll be
watching or I'm always keeping a podcast
or something on while I'm while I'm
working and and to be honest I I'll work
I'll have it on and if something I think
is really
um an organic conversation it pulls me
because I think the truth is so alluring
that if you're listening or you see it
and next thing you know I'm like I'm
watching Eric he's talking to Glassman
and they're making me laugh or they're
and I might watch something else based
on that that those guys are doing
because now you've hooked me and you're
doing something I'm like oh they're
talking some real or being real funny in
a real in a way that like speaks to me
because and and I know them right so I'm
like oh they're not just yapping for the
sake of like we have 10 more minutes
it's like they're on a they're on a
rhythm in a banter and which is great
you guys together by the way I know you
know what I mean a lot of people are
telling me this oh it's funny yeah and
sometimes you know you know what the
thing is that you know when you find out
something about someone that you didn't
know before and it changes your
perspective about them right it can
really enhance your relationship so like
for sure Rick is someone that he he has
autism okay he's autistic and I didn't
know this um so he was annoying the sh
out of me for years because he and he
didn't even know what it was right and
then when he figured it out and he told
me I had such a moment right Dana I I I
I was in tears right like I've I've had
conversations with Rick and I'll just go
to tears yeah because
I I get him more now of course you know
whereas before you guys didn't have we
didn't have that thing the full language
of being able to really receive what is
he doing this to frustrate me when he
knows I'm frustrated or because we're
Comics you know those Comics things like
I'll be on yeah I'm on all the time
and I thought anybody ever did that
around me by the way you'd see as the
quickest exit strategy search I'd be
like that door right there you know it's
just like somebody lying feline directly
from the door and you don't know someone
man it's like a weird thing dude you get
to know something that just changes so I
don't have a notebook but I do have a
notebook question uh what she told me I
would have come up with a notebook
question you already have but this is
one like for all of us it's like um when
he goes into high pitch voice yeah I
love it because you know he's just on
the brink of having a meltdown and then
it's like you can either push it a
little or just like okay easy you see
what I'm saying
what to deal with I picked up an 8K was
it loaded oh actually we're gonna talk
about that too we all play Warzone oh
you
he's actually a monster okay he's just
very he attacks War zones the way he
attacked his career I love it I love it
this is a good Trio this is a great Trio
right here
but you know it's funny just
Dane doesn't like streaming he don't
want to stream and he told me he said
listen man
I get into it
into the game I'm gonna be yelling I'm
gonna be saying things I'm super
competitive and he don't want people out
there being like damn that guy is crazy
it's like it's like I'm less funny
because I become yeah I feel you on that
my whole world is like oh we're not
getting into that oh here you think
you're bad this one is no we're not
gonna break a controller we're not I've
never broken a control I've broken it
you know hard it is to break a elite
thing I was Elite I'm doing very well by
myself
yeah yeah the humble brag he's got no he
has like a cabinet
there's another one but it's all the
same ones
[Laughter]
the point is we love words yes we love
Warzone but here's my question okay I'm
ready is there an adventure is there an
invention like if you can think back in
your life is there like an invention
that you think that you go wow that
really changed the world or changed your
world
has been a consistent question for
everybody I want to ask you because I
tell you one that I've been thinking
about for me it's the elevator like if
you think about how the elevator that
was I know
okay the elevator if you think about how
cities are built and how what goes on
and and how people live the elevator is
one of the most fantastic inventions
yeah to ever be invented you know the
earliest version of the elevator what's
that a river yeah because you'd walk all
the way up together at what you had and
then you'd take the canoe back down to
your you can also carry more right but I
just feel like the elevator made it so
we didn't have to live like this can
people online we can live once we all
have our our we should our picks we got
to put a poll on YouTube channel about
that please put a poll up for that the
elevator elevator is one of the greatest
inventions antibiotics is probably
second yeah right are you gonna say
antibiotics no no it's personal to you
I'm gonna tell you but it's your
I mean I'll there's nothing really
honestly that's been so crazy to me I
guess just the fact of like self-driving
cars because I'm gonna sound super
spoiled here like a little spoiled brat
but
um I've had my I just got my license
recently I just turned 24 and I got
around a year and a half ago ubering for
like 10 years okay it hasn't been around
10 years so
put that out there
um anyways so
yeah yeah jeez anyways so
um my girlfriend has a Tesla and I in
the matter of like one year I'm learning
how to drive and then you know we start
dating and then now I'm in in her car
driving and it just is self-driving that
to me and the fact in one and a half
years I went from getting my license
driving normal car to then being in a
car that drives myself like
just self-driving cars in general that
blows but is that really even happening
yet it is it is right now so people are
they're they're fully because they fully
automate it but fully you go on the
freeway okay not something he just said
it's so interesting for us being 49
right yeah this is how old are you I'm
49. okay we're reporting here's the
thing
Our Generation I think that we have seen
the most technological advancement 100
in the in our life in the shorter short
amount of time right than anybody in any
other generation because everything up
to 95 was a different kind of dude
everything I'm talking about yeah
just look at the telephone we went from
you know rotary and we had rotary phones
then we went to the push button then it
was like call waiting and and then
three-way calling we had that call
waiting oh you know what it is it's when
somebody else calls and you hear them
before there used to be a busy tone yeah
like we'd be on the phone and somebody
else would call and it would be like
and that would let you know that that
person's on the phone they're on the
phone that's what we had to deal with
look at his face there was a girl in my
neighborhood that I liked and if I
called three or four times and I got the
Busy Signal you called it I would open
my window and I would yell I'm trying to
call you and then finally she would hang
up and I could give you an emergency
break through like I couldn't
yeah yes
that is a wild it was just as a wild
coincidence man that was just a
coincidence that it was on 9 11. but
9-1-1 has always been the emergency
number wow I think he's watching today
I think they picked the data purposely
originally they were going to crash it
on 7-Eleven to ruin the yeah to ruin the
convenience store chain yeah they wanted
it they wanted to crash into a 7-Eleven
but the 7-Eleven
too soon
[Music]
before 9 11 it was is that a dumb
question super dope okay no that's not
dumb it was just asked this question to
someone before I'm like where did they
get that number for 9-1-1 and then I
always thought I was like oh was it
because like I didn't you know other
countries have adopted 9-1-1 only
because
of TV right because people watch these
shows and so other countries like they
they watch TV and they go the emergency
number is 9-1-1 so other countries have
adopted that too but that's so anyway
but just so you can answer the question
right it's a is it is interesting that
when he said that about like wow what
are the tech what are the advancements
because there are no real advancements
that have happened in this short of a
lifetime because every now everything's
just established just like we have the
iPhone so every version of the iPhone
we're just getting better version yeah
we had the first computer right I had a
Commodore 64. that's right you know what
I mean I did too and then we we do like
those I don't know what that is it was a
computer it had like the keyboard was
like six feet wide yeah yeah your desk
yeah empowered it yeah it had the
monitor had one color green yeah and
shades of green that was the first
computer man you know and then so we
think about like how video games so we
we saw that we saw where video games are
today right we saw like multiplayer came
along like late 90s to where finally you
could play other people anywhere in the
world I mean one of my earliest memories
it's funny because you're actually part
of my early memories when it comes down
to like
things I remember on like pop culture
and things like that and Halo 2 was
something where that was one of the
first games you could ever play with
other people yeah and I'm the youngest
of of four so I vividly have memories of
me playing Halo 2 and listening to your
stand-ups oh wow and I have even on my
first ever MP3 player had no screen on
it and my siblings had all your
stand-ups from iTunes yeah on it and I
would listen to them and I would be
going through them and I didn't see
which one was which but I would remember
like and I even remember one where
you're like thanks for the candy like
once like that like yeah yeah first
early Clips early early early ones and
like it's just it's it's wild to see how
far we come because like you said
there's not really been anything crazy
since then it's just been better version
of that that's true this generation is
doing now is they're getting rid of
Technology because it's so stupid like
who's got an eye iPod where's your iPod
you know no it's right here everything's
right here nobody has camera us nobody
has iPods nobody has DVD players nobody
has CD players we're streaming every
home automation
yeah dude so it's like all these things
are just making things better but you
know food delivery obviously everything
like yeah like but what's your invention
what's going into that there was only
one place that delivered uh Pizza in my
town growing up and get ready I worked
there years later I was one of my first
jobs like you know out of high school
and if you called and I didn't feel like
delivering your pizza I'd be like I'm
too busy and I just hang up there was
only one place that you could possibly
order you couldn't order other places
there was no uh they didn't even think
about it yeah so you had to hope that
the person at the pizza place was like I
got a few minutes I'll run something
over yeah pizza and Chinese food was the
only ones yeah in New York that's right
I remember I went to New York Chinese
food was like the one can we get some
Chinese food I don't know why yeah they
did they just figured it out why don't
we just take it to them yeah well I
discovered that New York and there was a
guy that would like bike to your place
with the the Chinese food delivery but
it felt unique it was like oh this one
place is going to bring me my food if I
throw them a little extra tip yeah and
so obviously now you've got nine apps
that deliver everything but I'll tell
you from me it's kind of similar to what
you said
but the biggest change for me was we
used to not have GPS in our car and you
had something called the Thomas guy we
talked about Thomas guy I was like what
and what in God's name is autonomous
guide is it like MapQuest it was like an
atlas book of the World by the way but
by the way atlas book but by the way you
an atlas is a book of maps you know whoa
and and
um the Thomas guy you also had to have a
degree from The Learning Annex to learn
how to to learn how to you know how to
play Battleship and have a degree for
the learning dude here's what I was so
ridiculous it was a book and let's say
you needed to get from you know here to
Fresno you'd be like I gotta get the
Thomas guide you got to open up Southern
California and then you'd be like okay
a11 you'd find you and then go okay I
gotta go from a11 and then you would
have to map out a route and keep that
book with you and you didn't know if
there were Road closers right right uh
detours dude forget accidents forget
going to Fresno how about going from
Bank to Culver City it would be like it
would be like f yeah and then you'd have
to be like okay so okay G then you got
to go to like right to go like seven
pages over to be like okay do you
remember the first time I remember the
first time how did you guys find
anything how did you get anywhere you're
late a lot okay you were late a lot yeah
everything I don't even know how to
reverse the car without a reverse cam
now so that's how I've Incorporated yeah
you know what I mean
the Thomas guide GPS becoming like you
know kind of a part of everyday life the
convenience of that feels like and I I
could have gone with like medical stuff
but I'm talking about like the
convenience of power life change yeah I
feel like daily life that puts so much
relaxation in your life because going
anywhere other than where you knew prior
to that wasn't sure yeah man oh wow
first of all you we had to this is the
thing that these kids don't get we had
to memorize every phone number in our
our every phone number of every person
we wanted to know we had to memorize our
number what about a thing of the phone
books I don't have phone book my mom's
got a phone book they had a it was
called a Rolodex a Rolodex yeah my dad's
got a rose actually yeah I've seen that
yeah wow you want to carry that around
yeah that's true what about it could be
a nerd you're just like just a second
I'm Stacy
you know so even all these things but of
course medical advancements and all
those kinds of things yeah those are
great inventions and they've changed the
world of obviously but I'm just saying
think of something that was personal to
you something you think wow what a great
invention or just it could be something
that from the past you go hey this I
think this is a great uh invention so I
don't know I I agree with you though GPS
was one of those ones that big game
changer again but like we we lived in
both that's what I'm saying is unique
about whatever generation this is or we
Z or what I don't know what we are what
are you guys yeah what are we identified
as
I don't know besides our generation I
don't even know we got to figure that
out but somebody an success generation
the success generator that's just how I
look at my generation yeah
you know what I gotta tell you you'll
have to think it right if you don't
think it in ruminate on success then how
are you gonna make it yeah you have to
have I made a comment about my when I
said yeah I mean when I get my first
Oscar and you're like this guy said his
first Oscar yeah he thinks Jinx do you
think manifest who will win yeah yeah
you know two different worlds all right
I know guys four million followers and
he's you know we've got two houses in
the Hills you know but you know it's
like do you here's another one off I
have a question too go back to me I
don't know we'll go to your question now
go I was going to say what about future
let's look down the road what do you
what do you hope is going to be a game
changer we've talked to him oh you have
done no no but this is good I like to
talk about it with new games okay I'm
glad you brought that up because I say
the only thing that's going to blow
these kids Minds is like teleportation
like it's gonna be like you know you
could be in Paris like I think it's I
think it's also space travel like
actually creating places we can live in
space on different planets I think
that's going to be the one where it's
like okay this is really happening like
we're if I have enough money I could get
a ticket to space I have the cash if you
want to go if this is okay coming
together you got space cash
I think one
ticket is like 250k or something
but you couldn't
to get back
you not going three times in a year okay
that's you philosophers
okay but I think the future
um it has to be like I think I think it
will be a medical advancements too I
think it'll be a thing more technology
is my pick oh yeah I think it's gonna be
a thing where it's like you need a new
kidney it'll be like that you know Star
Trek take the kidney pill and it's like
really I think uh uh
I think transplants and things like that
I think I think cloning
is going to be the thing that's going to
be like you have you need a new heart
then they can like boom you know I think
nanotechnology could kind of be ahead of
all that stuff though because you
wouldn't need the transplants and stuff
if nanotechnology is going through your
body and eradicating the the plaque
that's within your system through your
heart in your veins it's like they're
really close with that too microscopic
organisms that they injecting you go
through your body and like Nicks out all
the you know the the bad element but
they don't want that because then you
know the biggest problem with that would
be what
foreign
[Laughter]
oh man all right what's your question
yeah was that your question that was
kind of it I I was just like soothsayer
like what's the what's the future but I
think that we all kind of think it's
like space or medical or I had I had a
kid on my podcast his name is Dylan
dickstein and he's like trying to get
into the NASA program he's a super smart
kid you know and he's so interesting you
know I actually met him doing Logan
Paul's podcast he was just there hanging
out and he started talking to me about I
want to go to Mars but what what when
you start talking to him he he dumbs it
down for me right you know but it's very
much like explains it to you like a 12
year old yeah but we're like we're not
close you know we're not closer in terms
of like he still doesn't get us like try
nine-year-olds
talk to me like you are my first grade
teacher trying to teach me something
tell me a lie that makes me believe the
thing I already think I'm smart enough
to know because I just go so Star Wars
right it's gonna be just like that right
so I don't know we're just not close in
terms of like the human body being able
to take the the velocity of the travel
yeah and what space does to the body
right and uh you know remember those but
but it's in in at its simplest the
reason we can't go very far is water
water is the biggest issue yeah there's
no planets with water you can't you
can't but no you can't you can't you
know according to the movie a martian
with uh with uh
in the dirt and grow potatoes yeah you
believe that I love that movie though
have you ever read the book that looks
even better because it's even more
science I didn't read the book but I
really love that movie even though the
pooping in the the tent with the things
fertilizer yeah no I get it I I know I
know what he was making I'm just saying
but even in that thing they had like a
water we need a MythBusters and a doctor
in here because is it water it's not a
fact check water is hydrogen what is
water H2O it's hydrogen plus oxygen so
did you make water if you have a bunch
of hydrogen and oxygen it for from what
I understand if you ever listen to big
brains talking about why can't we just
go there and start building they always
go well water is a big issue yeah you
have to have a lot of water and I feel
like that comes down to weight too like
you're talking about making water like
yeah you can maybe make a few gallons
but then what not enough to last like
the six months travel to and they're not
even close to like in every movie what
do they do when they go on space travel
they go to sleep they go to sleep we're
not even close to that time yeah right
they're all they're all comedians in
that scene
three years of sleep that's me in Tampa
it's like you know when you watch Star
Wars I always used to wonder like why
are the the gold leader have to be like
a fat dude that looks like George Lucas
you know like everybody in the plane was
always just like no I would I don't
think that guy would have to be in shape
right Porky yeah that's what his name
was in the movie too oh was it yeah dude
remember porkies Porky's what's up Porky
a fat guy oh for a porker is what they
used to do people don't know this about
name but Dana is very much a nerd like a
super nerd all right and what in what
ways like oh a collectible nerd okay
because there's a lot of different
nerves
uh uh my knowledge of certain things and
like sci-fi and I can go on Deep dive
conversations when somebody starts
bringing up like the making of Star Wars
like I'm right there I'm like okay now
you're speaking my language well on that
topic I've always thought that
you know and people are going to be like
yo Matthew's crazy for this but I feel
like a lot of the people in the film
industry especially from the 70s and 80s
and 90s they knew something about space
they knew something somehow like how
were they able to make Star Wars how are
they able to know this much because a
lot of times we still go are going off
of what was made 50 years ago we're
going off of that idea of like with the
space travel and I was like it blows my
mind that they were that early on and
understanding of it and I feel like for
lack of better terms film and TV
conditions us for what's to come and I I
don't know maybe like Independence Day
is preparing us for some kind of mass
Invasion and like at least
where are you going to be when that
happens in one of my houses
they're gonna blow that up first that's
going to be bunker number 45 what do you
mean think about that yeah
no no we like them we like yeah
it's like the landing gear tears my
master bedroom off but it's okay I'm in
the kitchen uh yeah now I feel like I
just feel like what we don't understand
you know is similar to like you know
religion or anything like that you know
at least you know we we have these
thoughts and our imagination runs wild
and the problem not a problem but the
thing now is we have the technology to
whatever we have in our head we have the
ability to show that on screen right you
know so that's something that I find
that would be another you know in a way
that's uh really appealing to the human
eye like yeah like digestible to go like
this looks and feels very real oh you
know the first moment I felt that that's
the first moment I really felt that was
when I watched Jurassic Park in the
theater for the first time oh yeah when
that dinosaur came on the screen you
could tell it didn't look like separate
from the background the whole theater
was like oh yeah it was so amazing
because that was first time a CGI
created character was on the screen in
that way right so question would you be
able to still watch that today having
the knowledge you guys have with seeing
all the movies you've seen would you be
able to still immersive it's still okay
yeah okay there's a few he's a great
Storyteller there's a few movies that
like if you watch Terminator 2 James
Cameron's uh technology he used then
except for maybe one scene where the
robot's coming out of the fire it looks
a little wonky but it it's it you get
immersed in it because it looks that
good wow anything before that you start
to go like um being pulled out of it
because I disagree in a way that I
sometimes I go I can recognize CGI now
right and I don't mind it just CGI
because it's such a great story that's
being right if it's great yeah you get
over it quick and even yeah like you
said nowadays I also be like man that
helicopter is definitely CGI but I'm
like I'm okay with it the CGI and movies
that I like now is like you don't even
know that it's CGI like most movies like
if there's any kind of action or
whatever it's a lot of CGI going on but
when they have like a character and
that's why I love like in my DeLorean
that they used a doll I really loved it
all the Practical of using like a real
puppet I love that the baby Yoda was a
doll right you know it made I don't know
why it is not real
it drew me and I'm out you know breaking
news breaking news but you know what you
were saying about like where did they
pull that influence from to create those
kinds of films and and and and have that
what was the visual uh yeah what exactly
like it's called it's called books
we don't even have anything to go off of
so that to me blows my mind how do you
think of Star Wars I think if Morrison
Wells was alive today
or the worlds or some well Wells did
like radio plays before television yeah
you guys have to set up here in America
okay
I'll tell you but if you're looking like
I I got it
because I did have a blanket I think of
Orson bank right
and he had the technology available to
him right now I'd love to see what kind
of thing he would have uh come up with I
mean he was he was a uh a Fantastical
thinker so why wouldn't he be using it
to the hilt right but I think back uh
the first kind of geeky thing I did was
seventh grade I read a book called
charity of the Gods and the book is
still available and amazing to this day
and what it did is it was talking about
how in Egypt in the pyramids the
hieroglyphics that are on the wall the
carvings they they found that they were
representative of what we're talking
about now space there's there's uh
carvings of spaceships there's people
looking up at the sky and there's a
person sitting in a craft with with fire
coming out of it this is thousands of
years that it's been etched on the walls
of you know with sarcophagus and all
these other things this book when I was
in seventh grade was breaking down and
showing all the r art throughout history
paintings two three thousand years ago
you can Google this today that have
people you know uh near a lake a
painting of a lot of and then there's
something floating in the sky that the
artist was obviously like pulling from
something in history that floated above
them that was obviously mechanical
looking anyway you could do it deep dive
into that but what I think is when I
heard when I read charity of the Gods
and they broke down that there was a map
of the entire like east coast of the
United States and South Africa what that
used to look like back thousands of
years ago yeah those Maps were in
existence on those cave walls or in
those pyramids there was no technology
to get that high to make a map at that
point you couldn't walk down yeah it
would have to be somebody continent
somebody would have to walk what
there's a jetty there's a bush so I
think that like this was like the
version as I grew up seeing film and
television start to expedite those
Visions into like great you know not
always so great but storytelling the
visual medium of Storytelling but before
that it was all campfire stories or
things that were etched on a wall and
it's like just like like no I got in I
remember the first the first book I read
for pleasure well actually the first
book I read that I enjoyed as a little
kid I'm reading this book was Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory oh wow okay
you know and I read testing and I would
and I could read it over and over again
and I knew what was going to happen but
I'd still be reading like oh he's a
bunch of slime yeah yeah yeah yeah this
is it you know this is it yeah
I still read science fiction books did
you like really anticipate the page turn
you knew on page 87. it's going down I
read that book like like maybe 10 times
and I knew everything that was gonna
happen but I just enjoyed that I was
like that with uh Stephen King's uh The
Dark Tower series which started when I
was in a freshman in high school and he
wrote them over 20 years there was like
seven books but I was the same way I'd
read a chapter I'd go back and read it
again going I don't want to know but I
do want to know let me build up to it
again almost like you'd rewind a movie
today I even feel like uh when I first
read I would never do that sorry I
figured you up but I would have to
re-read the paging because I don't know
what I just read it's not because I'm
anticipating it but I'm just like what
did I do let me do this again hold up
yeah but now it's like oh we're just
inundated with like so much but now you
do it with an iPad and what I dig about
that is if I do with audio or with eyes
I don't even need it I can even read
these kids aren't even around listening
to Whoopi Goldberg read everything I
love audiobooks too myself I delve into
audiobooks I want to hear the narrator
by me is that like I don't like
audiobooks it's like a robot if it's
like the tree was super like I'm just
like yeah it's like I can't listen to
that I can't listen to that if it's like
an actual human being reading it to me
I'm like no I like when they're when
they're doing it like they're like
they're a dad and they're like Robin
Williams yeah
but I want to imagine the because
sometimes you could be reading something
and you're projecting your own feeling
into it why do I want you to tell me how
I should be emoting let me feel that
experience
it's just the only the fact is my own
voice in my head is too loud sometimes
so I can't even be like reading
something and then be like yeah but what
are you gonna have for dinner tonight
and I'm like oh my God okay yeah what am
I gonna have for dinner tonight I don't
know my brain is just do you dream in
music do you ever dream music yeah for
sure my goodness that happens for sure
do you ever dream music dream music it's
funny because I've never actually had
anyone ask me that question but I've
experienced it and the moment you asked
me I was I knew exactly what you were
talking about I wake up sometimes with a
song blasting so loud in my like not
immersion
but I wake up thinking oh I'm gonna wake
up next to a very loud radio yeah and
the second I wake up it stops but I'm
not hearing an interpretation of it I'm
I hear the actual song playing at full
blast until I wake up that's interesting
sometimes it's overlapping the entire
dream
that's so interesting oh I'll also say
one minute
conversations so many times to me I'll
be like your girl
and there you go
um no but the only time actually my my
brain can really get through a full page
without like just going in a whole
different world is a script and it's so
weird because growing up I've had so
many issues reading books to the point
where whenever we would have reading
sessions in in our classroom I would ask
the teacher if I could just write
instead and that's actually how I really
got into writing and like long stories
and all that stuff was because I had
literal issues paying attention to what
I was reading and it wasn't kind of ADHD
kind of thing or I I'm guessing I do
I've never really gotten fully touched
but I could like 99.9 my brother said I
have ADHD so which I agree
no no but I I don't I didn't take that
offensive because at the end I feel like
I do have it but I don't even think it's
necessarily a um a handicap I'd look at
it as just like everyone is different
and they have everyone's brain works a
different way we just like putting
labels on things oh yeah
yeah I mean that to you I think if you I
think if you Wrangle anything like that
like we talk about Rick and some people
would think like somebody on the
Spectrum somebody on the Spectrum
somebody I want on my team because
they're focused and there's No Frill
Superfluous ego they're going to be very
direct with you about whatever it is
that they're feeling or seeing and I I
appreciate that let me tell you
something my I I go I have an accountant
and so like I was I was like taxes were
coming I was dealing with all this stuff
and then so I was in a room with three
of the accountants
three of the weirdest people I've ever
met like like just no Stigma here I'm
just saying I don't say weird episode
you're feeling I'm just saying they were
all like on the Spectrum and then I
thought oh yeah like this is where I
want this because it was like you know
it was it was so like I was like wow
like I saw genius at work that's what
I'm right well that's you know what I
mean but that's what I saw it at work it
was like one was like with the numbers
and knew everything why if you do this
one was shaking the other one was like
very very like you know and I was like
this is it I had to trust that the
voices in my head sometimes that were
screaming over me I had to relinquish a
little bit of my power to myself to go
maybe I should be following the louder
voice
and as long as it's not causing me to to
exhaust myself because I'm really not
obtaining anything I'm only just going
voice to voice what I found was it's
almost like you're having an argument
you're head going but this is really
what I'm supposed to be doing and
instead I'm focusing on something that's
not even really important to me and
that's what you're saying the louder
voice is like your conscience I'm I'm
saying that sometimes it's it's I I wish
I was smart enough to know like the
medical jargon but it's almost like
that's the lead dog in you going this is
real like something else might be you're
fixated or you have a little OCD or
something that's pulling you towards not
the narration of really where you should
be focusing and where you should be
going you need to kind of like listen to
those voices sometimes and go
let me put all the other ones away and
go with this one that's telling me like
no this is the right idea well yeah and
that's the thing too like it's really a
balance of knowing when to listen to
that voice because it's like you could
be focusing on something and then your
brain takes you somewhere else you'll be
like okay well that louder voice is tell
me to do this but then you have to
really sit back and then think about it
real time okay but now should I do this
or should I do that and like but and I
am glad that times in my past I have
listened to the voice in my head and
been like yeah I can do this a different
way hey teacher um instead of me reading
this book and then having to write about
it you know can I just write my own
stories like well and do you have
teachers that allowed that yeah I'll
never I'll never forget my teacher Miss
shriner in fifth grade we had to do a
reading log where we had to read a book
and for the first six months of the
school year I would just reread the same
book Diary of a Wimpy Kid the only
reason I like this because I'm a very
visual person they would have random
little pictures in it of like describing
what was going on every other like page
or whatever so I know that sounds so
super like oh you need a picture book in
fifth grade but like I didn't think like
I was like oh I want to see these
pictures
yeah so like but I just kept on redoing
the same thing I I'd read the same first
volume then do the second one do the
third and then I eventually was like
listen I'm not learning anything here
I'm just reading the same books to give
you something so can I just talk to you
about maybe writing something and she
was like are you just gonna write your
name a bunch and like well everyone's
reading for an hour you're just gonna
keep writing Matthew over and over again
because you're writing I'm like no no I
will write ascending Thanks for
believing in me no no no no she thought
I was trying to trick her I mean that
was a valid question a 5th grader is
asking you to write you think you could
get away with something by just right oh
yeah I'm writing teacher don't worry
you could just write the same thing over
and over again but I was like no I'll
write a cohesive you know like
comprehensible like chronological story
The Dream student and then um that's
what got me really into that's when I
wrote my first story called killer
cookie and it was like a 12 chapter
story about a cookie who uh who lost his
family to another family who was going
to eat his family because he's a cookie
and he had to go and capture them and he
got so mad because by the time he got
there they were already being baked and
then you're bringing that you're
bringing that here and we're rating it
we're going to read it yeah this I'm not
even kidding it's intense killer cookies
okay and this is in fifth grade it's a
pretty dark story because he ends up
getting get this ready my name is Dane
Cook and we're all here today
Serendipity oh well there you have it it
is actually actually that is probably
where because we're at an hour well I
have one last question because you're
good yeah 102. he always knows this is
for you both this is something I've I've
wanted to ask I actually have two
questions so I'm gonna need you guys for
a little bit longer what is the
difference what is the balance for you
guys when you're on stage the balance
between mean and funny and has that
changed over the years
because
for me I love roasting my friends I'm a
troller I love doing that I think it's
great and I wouldn't do it to someone
unless I feel like they know who I am
and they know it's coming from a a place
of you know friendship where does that
lie with you guys where is that where's
that line I think it's all about uh the
setup it's all about the context of what
you're talking about okay you know
because to some people being mean is
funny or or but if the context is I'm
saying something mean to my friend and
and it because it's mean because it's my
friend is why it's funny I mean I'll
give you a perfect let me give you a
perfect real world example we're talking
about Dane and I are chatting we're
talking on the the things we're playing
war zone and uh you know the World's
opening back up and then you know they
go uh well they're at like 25 capacity
and then Dane says that's like your
regular shows Eric so you know
you know what I mean you know what I
mean but then we said it in a way that's
like it's like okay so that's how you're
you know so you're but I know you as
well yeah and you wouldn't randomly say
that to someone who you saw so I'm
saying context matters about why
something's mean so that's why in a
stand-up set your setup is important so
people can establish oh I get why you're
saying this it doesn't always work right
and I think that that's the answer to
that yeah I think when people know that
uh like I'm not a malicious person but I
can say pretty cutting things and I have
a uh obtuse sense of humor that
sometimes I think Twisted thoughts I
want to observe and report but I think
[__] up stuff but my heart's in the
right place and that's all that matters
I think that if you're a person I think
a I think a person can go up and say
something that everybody interprets as
mean just because they might have anger
or whatever is living inside them and
that's what you see yeah but I think
that if you're a good person and you're
living a relatively you know cool
existence you know not not nefarious I
think people know that you're not
looking to you know make people feel bad
ad even though the comment might yeah
but but you know one doesn't mean at all
you can't just get generalized off that
I also think another thing that plays
into it is like remember this is a
visual and it's a performance
you're you can say something like if we
could say the same exact sentence and
it's going to be taken differently me
saying it than you saying it right
because you all get a laugh and you
might not
want to do that why did I even do it
more about yourself
as well and I like this please finish
that because I think that's important
for people to understand because it's
like how like because it's like your
voice you know you have one of those
voices that's like the the aliens are
about to attack and the voice that comes
on the monitor is going to be your voice
it's gonna be like guys get your section
A get your section right right you have
like so sometimes you might be saying
something and and it gets lost in the
interpretation because also you know and
just be real in this day and age when
you're a straight white male you can't
necessarily say some of the things that
someone else could say right exactly nor
should you probably be yeah but even
sometimes unless it's your truth and it
can be can be interpreted a certain way
so that's why again when you're doing a
performance a lot of it really is about
like how am I setting this up how am I
right what's the context of what's
happening in the room yeah but a lot of
young a lot of young Comics the whole
thing about being a young Community is
like being a little kid a little kid
wants just to understand discipline even
though in the moment they don't think
they do but that they want to know what
are my boundaries a young comedian wants
to shock you they want to take the air
out of the room they want to walk the
room sometimes just for the not for the
sake of like saying I bombed but just to
be like how much chaos could I can I can
I control here we all did that at the
beginning you know what I mean until you
start to learn like oh there's a more
interesting way to tell jokes than
having having to rabble Rouse the whole
room okay well my second question my
last one is do you think that has to do
with also hecklers and does your
comments change based on that dude what
is like a good Heckler story like does
like yeah this is the whole now this is
a different thing yeah part two because
this is
because I've had times where it's like
man I got too angry
at this because then you'd lose sight of
like you're still at a show yeah people
are paying to see each other so even
though this person is like right there's
a way to handle that yeah and if you're
in a good spirit about it there's a way
to handle it of course really destroy
this person right and have everybody
still be like oh this is great and and
that's part of the show because you also
know that people are expecting all right
now the comics is going to bury this
person yeah how much do you bury them
yeah yeah and how happy are you that
they just got bare you know so it is oh
I've put Scarlet letters on people I've
I've tattooed people I've said things
that 10 years later people wrote me and
say we still call them the nickname that
you told us to based on how he disrupted
the show or your level of crude in in uh
in heckling whatever you bring to me I
kind of do the math and go all right
that was really [__] up I'm now I'm
gonna go back or something 10 times yeah
okay you're just drunk and you're like
kind of silly I'm gonna be I'm gonna
make you're gonna you're gonna match the
energy well sometimes though you
sometimes it depends on like let's say
you you just wrote this you just you
gotta you gotta you're doing a bit right
and you're in the middle oh yeah
yeah it's gonna tie this all together
and this place is gonna be rocking and
rolling right and then some head you
have something to say yeah uh a woman
came to the live Factory two weeks ago
I'm five minutes into a set and I'm
already on the first wave like I'm like
riding you're cruising yeah yeah she
puts her hand up and I went I looked and
I got and she went like this like and I
said some stuff like this is in a
seminar but I'm getting a little lost
but finally I am I'm fascinated I go but
I want to know I stopped my bit I go
what is it she goes
do you have any other jokes
no and the whole crowd the air goes out
and everybody goes oh because they they
think and I think at first oh she's
saying this isn't funny and I don't like
it yeah she then muttered I saw your
show last week she I said well then the
problem is you come to too many shows
because these people haven't heard it
they didn't care the audience was out
for blood they didn't know that she was
saying it because she'd heard the joke
and she wanted to hear something
different they thought she just didn't
think I was funny yeah so therefore I
had to murder her with words
understandable yeah the audience called
for It Like Gladiator they were like
yeah
that's the only time I'm in stand-up uh
how long you been here I'm 30 years oh I
have 2003. okay so I'm 30 years in to
stand up and except for those first ten
which yeah definitely said things that
were like I'd go home later and be like
oh I can't believe I I would say that on
stage yeah I was unbridled sometimes but
in my professional career
there's never moments that I'm looking
to to ruin somebody's day for sure but
when my ego has been in check and in
moments where I haven't been completely
like happy in my own skin I have people
up yeah and that's the only time I've
gotten like me I remember saying to I
remember I was in like Texas or
something I'm just a woman is like and I
said to her you need to stop
congratulations
anymore
you're gonna be outside crying you know
you're gonna be outside crying you need
to stop and sure enough the bouncer came
out to me later it was like and then and
I felt bad the way he did it too because
he went oh man she was crying you know
I can't do that you know why let me tell
you why and then we'll go after this we
are like Kung Fu Specialists and if
we're at a bar are we allowed to say
Kung Fu specialist yeah kung fu kung
Fu's a thing yeah we're a Kung Fu look
it up and we're like you're like a black
belt in kung fu let's go Taekwondo okay
Taekwondo and you're at a uh you're at a
bar and some drunk guy or whatever mess
is messing with you you know you can I
say drunk guy let's call him inebriated
gentleman this guy they didn't cook
everybody I just want to be careful
[Music]
I'm gonna get you in more hot water than
you're already in from half the things
that you've said on this and they're
like you can't beat this person up I
think that verbally yeah it's illegal
because your fists are like your illegal
weapons yeah I feel like I feel like
that
we have a Lethal Weapon yeah sometimes I
tell them too I go you're not gonna win
this right just for the simple fact that
I have a microphone and speakers like
even that people paid me back
constitution on myself with what I'm
about to you to do to you right so then
you like verbally come full yeah it does
it does happen and when it does there's
from time to time you do look back and
you go like oh I scored that person
maybe a little bit yeah a little bit too
much but I felt that yeah well listen
guys uh you guys are coming by yeah this
has been uh sent to Jen Dane Cook thanks
dude uh pleasure having you here yeah it
was great um you know well next time
we'll just do all nerd stuff maybe with
a doctor
[Laughter]
whether you're watching or listening we
appreciate you guys stopping by to uh to
engage with us Dane thank you so much
for coming by absolutely man pleasure
meeting you and uh okay he shook his
hand because I was on the proper
right-handed right there and then if we
did this I would be like this
well thank you everybody for watching be
sure to like subscribe follow everything
you got to do we'll see you guys next
week on gentichen and uh I think that's
a wrap
[Music]